how to sell online to the American
market if you're starting the business
online and you want to get people buying
from you the u.s. is a great mark of the
target huge consumer base lots of money
to spend but you have to make it easy
for them to do it and reduce the risk if
you're looking at an American buyer and
I've sold to the US and I'm from Canada
i'm not american but i sold a lot into
the u.s. if you're from the US and
you're selling to the US it's a lot
easier there's a lot less fear as soon
as you're asking somebody to buy from a
country outside of their own it
increases the fear it increases the
certainty and so you have to do a good
job in reducing that fear and giving
them more certainty if you want to be
able to make more sales I got a question
from one of my readers on youtube I
squash fools that's his name anyway good
name so he's an entrepreneur in south
asia wants to create a new online store
that sells clothes to the american
market and wanted my advice on what to
do should he have a store in the u.s.
wondering how do i get this started so
again you need to make this super easy
for people to buy from you and the
biggest issues that ipad in looking at
products that are overseas and deciding
whether to buy them or not have been one
dryness in the pricing so i almost never
buy anything that it's outside US or
canada online unless i really really
really really really have to have it and
nobody in north america sells it because
i don't understand the pricing first of
all i don't understand what that dollar
means so somebody's listen something in
euros or in a asian currency or any
other currency i don't i don't know what
that means to me in canadian dollars or
in u.s. dollars and i don't want to do
the work to find out unless i really
love the product so you have to make it
easy so you want to reduce the risk you
want to increase certainty show them how
much it's going to cost in US dollars it
makes it a lot easier the next thing is
clearly show what the shipping is going
to be another big fear is if you're
buying something from a foreign market
is how much it's going to cost to ship
is it going to break my arm to pay for
this huge shipping cost because it's
going to cost more in shipping coming
from another country than coming from
within your own country so make that
clear
I will not buy products online because I
don't know what the shipping cost is and
I don't want to go through the effort of
asking the website how much is it going
to cost to ship this to me make it easy
show them up front here's how much it's
going to cost to ship to your location
and the third thing is having some kind
of credibility right you want to show
that other people have bought from you
and had success and love buying from you
and that reduces the fear that you're
going to screw me right if I've never
boxing before and you're in a different
country I'm worried that I'm going to
send you my money and you're not going
to give me anything back that's going to
be a fierce you have to get over that
fear with people and show them that you
are a credible source the place that
I've actually bought the most
international stuff from is ebay and one
of the things that they do really well
is cover those three areas that I talked
about so the pricing you get the pricing
in your local currency so I know how
much is going to cost me in Canadian US
dollars to buy the product they show me
what the shipping is up front they tell
me how much is going to cost to buy this
product and how long does it take the
ship and there is credibility built-in
in that they show me how many people
have bought from the for what the
reviews have been before and so I'm
willing to take the leap and buy
something from an Asian country or
European country a country that I've
maybe never bought from before because
ebay helps reduce my risk so that's
going to be your child as to be
something you need to go through on your
own side show me the pricing show me the
shipping reduce my risk it may even make
sense a start on ebay to build up a
profile to build up testimonials and
reviews and build that into your website
to say here's all the success that we
had on ebay here's all the reviews and
the testimonials and people love working
with us to again help reduce the fear
the uncertainty the doubt that people
will have in dealing with a country that
they may not have ever bought from the
forum put those strategies to work for
you and you'll have a lot more success
in selling to the US market believe so
those are watching like the video please
give it a thumbs up below it always
makes you want to do more for you and
let me know what you think you have a
comment about this video leave it below
are you selling to the US market let me
know what you think you have a question
for your business something totally
unrelated leave it in
comments I'll make a response for you
thank you so much and I'll see you soon